when we think of objects that are
synonymous with Japan and anime not much
can be the symbolic metallic behemoths
that have cemented themselves into
history
[Music]
meh Casas Jana is one let's capture the
hearts of fans for decades and has a
history almost as rich and expansive as
the medium of anime itself love it or
hate it there are a few things that are
as iconic for anime and even if you
don't consider yourself a mecha fan it's
more than likely that one of your
favorite series has its roots from this
genre in recent times however the sad
reality is that whilst mecha by no means
died out it's not even close to being
the medium defining Titan it once was
sure you may see a show or two pop up
here and there and Gundam has had its
steady stream of shows seemingly forever
but nothing's really broken out from the
sphere of the dedicated mecha fandom how
did such as onra Titan fade from the
mainstream anime consensus what journey
did this titular genre take to get here
with such a rich history there's an
interesting story to be told here one so
expansive there's no way I can fit
absolutely everything in this video but
I will try my best so strap in your seat
belts cuz it's gonna be a long one as
it's a tale that dates back to the roots
of anime itself one that starts in the
1950s on the back of a pretty big war
that apparently the entire world got
involved in
[Music]
it's impossible to talk about the roots
of animes we know it without mentioning
the events of a bloke with a weird
mustache deciding he hated the Jews one
days and attempting to fight the entire
world to prove that point and more
importantly the aftermath from it given
how much an event like 9/11 influenced
modern media today you can only imagine
how huge a cultural impact of having two
massive bombs dropped on your country
would be and this was certainly
reflected in the stories that would be
largely credited for the birth of anime
and Mecca mighty Adam better known to us
in the West as Astro Boy was certainly
the series with the greatest cultural
significance of its time
Osamu Tezuka's manga first began
publishing in 1952 just a few short
years after the climax of world war ii
and heavily features themes of peace and
understanding between all nations borne
in part to Tesla's experience and hatred
for war and nuclear weaponry Astro Boy
may not have even been close to what we
consider Mecca by modern standards being
a story about a fully sentient Android
but the messages have spread and the
culture it created would lay the
groundwork for what would soon come to
follow it for the series that can
without a doubt be credited as being the
first in the genre of mecha would soon
begin publishing in 1956 a story about a
ten-year-old boy being given a remote
control of a 60-foot robots by his
father a super weapon created by the
Japanese army in a fictional Pacific War
tetsujin 20 gates go can truly be
considered the grandfather of mecha and
the progenitor of super robots as a
concept much like Tesco with Astro Boy
Yokoyama has experience living through
the Second World War was one of the
driving inspirations for him to create
this mechanical monster with one of his
other key influences being in the 1931
Frankenstein film and his reasons for
applying that idea to this work
fundamentally describes one of the
biggest things mecha stands for as a
concept the monster machine or nuclear
weapon is not in and of itself good or
evil the evil lies in the intent of the
Creator and how it's used
these were cultural phenomenon that was
set the president's not just for anime
but Japan's wider culture as a nation
now intertwined with technology robotics
and automation you can see when this
interest sparked from and how integral
these stories are to capture the
consensus of a war-torn nation and this
would continue on into the 70s as the
interest in giant robots would only
increase the super robot boom was about
to begin
[Applause]
[Music]
tetsujin twenty-eight go may have laid
the groundwork where the 70 saw the
floodgates open with numerous ideas
being introduced for the very first time
that would become the defining tropes of
the genre and right to the forefront was
going a guy the same man who everyone
decided to start paying attention to
again thanks to his influential work
being adapted in devil man cry-baby
as far as my car is concerned however
there's arguably none more important
than his implementation of the very
first timer series depicted a robot
being piloted from inside the machine
itself Mars Inga's II took what tetsujin
had begun and firmly defined what super
robots meant as a genre as before this
the robots were either sentient beings
as with Astro Boy and giant Robo or
intensity ins case it was controlled
remotely with a handset for what may
seem like an obvious and unimportant
development to some the matter of the
fact is this is part of the criteria we
now use to define what a mech actually
is a humanoid machine being piloted from
within this new idea firmly established
what would define this decade this was
the era of giant mechanical superheroes
rocket punching hand drilling and chest
lasering their way through a week on
week assembly line of evil villains and
monsters the shows that came along to
capitalize on the popularity and
development brought about by the likes
of Mars in Jersey and get a robo began
to define the episodic
monster-of-the-week format were so
familiar with in anime it was a decade
of brightly colored mecha shows for
children and thus began the other aspect
that would go hand in hand with the
genre merchandising every single one of
these shows was marketed from the ground
up with the intent to sell robot toys to
kids and it was this aspect that would
decide whether or not a show was
successful this factor would stick with
the genre to this day and merchandising
would become a huge driver of what mecha
has become today thus of course with so
many shows coming out year-on-year
building themselves on the ideas that
came before them it wouldn't take long
until the Super Robot genre starts
become stale and monotonous the audience
were hungry for something new setting
the stage for something big to happen
and while some aspects of sci-fi and
Technology branched off with iconic
shows like Leiji Matsumoto Space
Battleship Yamato
opening up the space opera genre
something needed to happen to completely
revolutionize what defines mecha
turns out this would come from an
up-and-coming director by the name of
Yoshiyuki Tomino as in April of 1979 the
mecha Ward was introduced to the
game-changer that defines game
Changez an entirely new genre within
Mecca was about to make huge waves in
the industry and nobody was ready for
the phenomenon that we would still feel
to this day
[Music]
to say that Mobile Suit Gundam was an
important series is a bit of an
understatement akin to saying the
universe is fairly large or I am quite
fond of cinder ace this would spawn the
real robot genre one depicting the
machines as true tools of war
essentially tanks with legs instead of
mechanical Superman it was the very
first anime to depict a fictional human
on human war to this level as throughout
the decade previous it was always
monsters or evil alien races opposing
the heroes Gundam was the exact
antithesis to this idea for whilst you
are firmly experiencing the war from one
side's perspective the motivations and
goals of all parties involved were
purely justified this moral ambiguity
was completely unheard of at the time as
was the concept of a young civilian
protagonist being thrust into a world he
didn't understand sound familiar to any
anime you've seen recently the mature
themes were a huge departure from the
kid-friendly super robots so much so in
fact that initially the show was cut
short and ended up a commercial failure
in many respects as with before
merchandising is a huge driver for Metro
as hell the only reason why the very
first Gundam was depicted in this iconic
color scheme of red white blue and
yellow was for the sake of merchandising
and kids just weren't incentivized to
buy it
it wasn't until the film compilations
had finished screening in 1982 that
again the recognition it deserved was
merchandising that was targeted towards
an order audience in Gunpla once that
happens though oh boy were people fully
aware just how much of a big deal Gundam
was and it firmly stood to have exactly
the same effect on real robots that Mars
Ngozi had on super robots in the decade
prior unlike the 70s though the more
mature subject matter and serial nature
of real robot narratives meant that all
manner of shows got presents fresh and
compelling ideas the established tropes
of super robot anime were rapidly
phasing into live-action sentai leaving
in this place what is truly considered
to be a golden age of mecha this era saw
the rise of such incredible franchises
as Doug Rambo Tom's patlabor
and most notably of all outside of
Gundam super dimension fortress macros
Shoji Khao amore would soon become a
hugely impactful figure an icon within
the mecha world but what a way to make a
name for himself with this show perhaps
and somewhat unfortunately though
depending on who you ask there was a key
theme featured in mat cross that would
go on to have a very important
they ship with Macker in future years
that being the integration of
[ __ ] idols yes that's right
trace it back far enough you'd find some
of the rooster idol shows in mecha anime
Mecca was the defining genre for anime
in this time but towards the end of the
decade like when the hot trend was super
robust a similar low in quality was
beginning to set in as a result of the
over saturation of real robots jumping
on the Gundam bandwagon the landscape
was once again ready for a change and
just before the 80s ended an
up-and-coming animator by the name of
Hideaki anno joined the fray with his
directorial Debbi gunbuster as well as
being an absolutely fantastic series
overall Gunbuster was a firm sign of
things to come with a successful
blending of classic super robot motifs
with modern serious story elements and
characterization this fusion of ideas
would soon go on to define the future of
the genre as we go on into the 90s mecha
would transition into somewhat of an
identity crisis
[Music]
the biggest thing to differentiate the
90s the previous decade was that Mecca
didn't stick to a particular trend and
it was an incredibly experimental and
very time the genre became a potent
cocktail of fresh takes on classic
genres and completely new concepts to
firmly establish how limitless the idea
was from a story perspective Gundam saw
in the UN original takes between the
likes of G Gundam in the franchise's
first take on super robots - a thermos
team perhaps being the greatest most
down-to-earth example of definitive real
robots combats to date it was clear the
gloves were off for mecha at this point
the lights of ghoul guy garb or super
robust back into the public eye in a big
way and showed you Kara more his biggest
hits since Matt cross in escaflowne with
his fantasy Sakai setting pushed the
limits of what people expected from the
genre even through all this however 1995
would proved to be the defining year of
this decade with two of the biggest and
most important shows this genre has ever
seen hitting screens not only in Japan
but for the West as well Gundam Wing was
my generations gateway into mecha thanks
to its successful Toonami run it was
everything as far as mecha in the West
was concerned and I'm sure many of you
who have this show in particular to
thank for introducing you into the genre
but of course whilst it was still
popular in Japan its impact was
borderline irrelevant compared to that
of Hideaki Arno's career-defining icon
of this medium
if Mobile Suit Gundam were to be
considered the defect a game changer for
mecha then neon genesis evangelion would
prove to have an impact of a similar
scale but to the entire medium of anime
it's hard to pinpoint specific aspects
of Ava that would go on to define the
future of mecha as a genre it didn't do
what Mar thing as Z and Gundam did and
starts some kind of boom of Ava clones
across the following decade it simply
became a bastion for otaku culture as a
whole it revolutionized the medium as we
know it today and ironically enough
waffle once the merchandising wasn't the
main point to its initial success it has
become arguably the most commercialized
franchise in Japan doing for the
Japanese what star wars did for the West
to boil down Ava's influence to just a
few points with entirely on the sell the
impacts this series had I could go on
for hours about exactly what it did for
anime but that's a topic for another
video and we're here to talk about ones
onra as the true deciding element of
what Ava did for mecha is the simple
fact that is showed to a mass audience
that you do not need to be a mecha fan
at heart
to enjoy a series with giant robots in
it yes we can point at the stim lines
biomechanical designs are different from
everything that came before them how it
took from the established aspects of
mecha while subverting a lot of them
where the genre conventions of mecha
were not what's made neon genesis
evangelion what it was it was simply a
component of its brilliance it's made
people who weren't fans of the genre pay
attention to it it pushed for the genre
to be one that wasn't defined by its
pre-established tropes and trends it's
Eva that allowed for many fan favorites
that have come since to be noticed and
loved by everyone a lot of which aren't
even mecha shows mecha was no longer
just a monster of the week battle series
it was no longer just political driven
war stories or a combination of the two
it was none of those things it was all
of those things and so so much more so
what came next was what I could only
describe as the modern Golden Age of the
genre
[Music]
the 2000s wasn't a period of development
or progress for the genre it was simply
a period of pure fulfilling payoff for
everything Mecca given us over the last
30 years Mecca fans just wanted great
shows great stories and great characters
and that's exactly what they got shows
like rahxephon parading Ava's influence
in spades to great success Full Metal
Panic masterfully blending real robots
with high school comedy a record sevens
coming-of-age adventure rekindling how
well Mecca is blended itself with
romance in the past he'll love it or
hate it
Gundam Seed was a big [ __ ] deal in
terms of overall popularity the rebuild
of evangelion films were just starting
gun bus's eventual sequel and die buster
brought back super robots and this would
all peak in 2007 with the release of two
shows that to this day stands as mecca's
last big hurrah in the wider anime
consensus just who the hell do you take
tengen toppa gurren lagaan
wasn't just a big show it was a galaxy
sized fandom wide phenomenon of the
times that appeal to and was loved by
just about everyone back then and still
to this day this was the exclamation
mark on the end of an iconic lineage of
the Super Robot genre and I captured the
hearts of a generation of fans who
probably hadn't even heard of any of the
shows that inspired it to be it remains
to this day one of the defining shows in
the modern anime generation and with
that said it's amazing to think that I
might not have even been the biggest
mecha show of that year
[Music]
Code Geass top things off and like how
gurren lagaan gave us a true to its
roots Super Robot Show Code Geass gave
us a true to its roots pearl it's called
real robot series and breathe new life
into a genre that had previously just
been dominated by the Gundam franchise
loudly exclaiming two new fans here's
what's cool about the genre these shows
one popular because they were mecha
shows they were popular in spite of that
and they made people into mecha fans the
influence and legacy of everything from
tesage in through Mars in a Z mobile
suit gundam Evangelion and Beyond had a
huge payoff over these few short years
this golden age however would be
short-lived for as we move on now just
over ten years later mecha simply has
not flourished in the same way since
[Music]
so here we are today the gradual decline
of a genre that was once the juggernaut
of this medium now I'm by no means
saying there haven't been any great
series over the last 10 years but it
should be clear to everyone by now the
mecca is nowhere near as prevalent as it
used to be
Gundam has been reduced to OVA z-- which
mainly appealed to the hardcore fans
with iron blooded orphans failing to
garner the mass appeal it really needed
the small amount of new your IPS have
fallen flat even though the likes of
Star Driver Captain Earth out no zero
Knights of Cydonia and valvrave have
tried none have come close to succeeding
and if you're a dedicated make a fan the
chances are that you've become a
minority in the modern anime community
how did this happen it would be easy to
say that trends come and go and in the
genre that there's 60 years old now
there is little room for something new
and innovative but now having looked
through its rich history I believe the
problem could run deeper than that and
there are two main points I want to
address firstly is the current landscape
of our time Mecca found its roots from
the impact of World War 2 and because of
this war has always been a prevalent
theme in the genre war against an
oppressor war against an unknown entity
the moralities of war is something that
we as humans have had to deal with
throughout our history but right now war
isn't that the forefront of the general
consensus relatively speaking we're in a
more peaceful time without the worry of
war Twitter dick-measuring contest is
about nuclear weapons aside and in its
place are the fight for social political
issues or localized tragedies war
stories just don't captivate us as much
as they used to and grant epic mecha
warring plot lines have less of a place
in this time not only that for the last
game of anime itself has changed we are
in a time of the seasonal competitive
hard-hitting 13-episode anime series and
for a genre that generally likes to tell
compelling epic tales that require the
time investment of developing a large
cast in building a rich world it's hard
to compete fact of the matter is you'd
usually need at least 25 episodes to
tell a decent mech story with 50
episodes being the optimal after this
many episodes be planned and approved
from the get-go is becoming increasingly
rare in this day and age and even rarer
if you want to do it for a new IP not
forgetting that it still has to compete
with every other seasonal anime meaning
if it doesn't grab an audience in the
first three episodes it'll likely be a
flop the second big thing as with
everything else in this world is money
maker series are expensive to produce
not just because of
commitment of a high episode counts as
we just discussed but because of the
nature of the shows and the Mex
themselves recent times have seen the
rise of using CG to depict mechs and as
subjective visits may be I think I speak
for a lot of us by saying the new
standard of CG robots are just less
aesthetically appealing than the mechs
evolved and have failed to capture the
modern audience the same way nightmare
frames are blessed and near Vash did for
my generation this is not to say that CG
is a product of lack of funds CG mechs
can look good and have looked good but
it seems like all the time money
resource and talent to make them look
good according to oh yeas now which I
suspect is to appeal to the hardcore
fans because only they at the moment
feel the prevailing lifeblood of mecha
merchandising history has taught us that
this genre lives and dies by
merchandising and the hot things now
aren't gun claws the patience and skill
needed to build your own model kits
caused them to have a much higher
barrier for entry than simply buying a
figure of your favorite digitized waifu
it becomes a hobby rather than a casual
purchase meaning they end up appealing
to the dedicated hardcore fandom as
opposed to the mass audience keeping
them happy with high quality over yeas
they will definitely appreciate instead
of a big push to appeal to the casual
viewer Mecca it seems just isn't as
profitable for mass audience anymore and
in its place has seen the rise of new
trends ISA Kai Shonen mo a slice of life
all fits better in this modern landscape
and make more money - and I think the
most interesting thing to come out of
this story is with the rise of idol
shows for as I mentioned earlier you can
see the early roots of idols sprouting
from Mecca and whether it's been akb48
Idol Master Zen a glossy or matte cross
the two genres have always been
connected but while the original matte
cross is more remembered for its mecha
elements the same is no longer true for
the franchise as Makris Delta's main fan
base interactions comes from their idol
group hell if we look at studio sunrise
the Gundam studio the studio that
thrives on its love for giant robots we
can see that has not been Gundam that's
been their money-making machine for the
past decade it's love life love life is
the property that has allowed the studio
to thrive in the modern age yes you
heard it here first
idols killed mecha anime this of course
is all my own speculation from looking
at the history as there is no definitive
answer for why it has happened but
whatever the reason
has found itself in a sorry States
compared to its yester years and whether
there will be something to reignite it
back into its glory days only time will
tell what could the future hold for this
genre it may be too late for a Gundam
series to ever have the same level
popularity the likes of wings seed or
double-o did as the simple matter of
fact is with how dense the history of
Gundam is now it's a very daunting
franchise to undertake for new fans
overall it is still going strong though
and likely will always be around
considering how symbolic it is we'll
just choose to ignore the fact that even
Gundam has conformed to new trends now
with the next build fighters being based
around a VR MMO we can probably expect
idols to show up somewhere as well it's
not all gloom though as 2018 lives to be
the most exciting year for the genre in
a very long time darling in the Franks
is one of the most popular shows this
season Code Geass and Full Metal Panic
of both getting sequels after over a
decade and CDO Trigger have even more
mecha outings in the work the genre is
still very much around and could still
thrive again it's just waiting for that
next big breakout hit to push it into an
ongoing trend because without this
without that show that brings in new
blood into the mecha phantom the same
way Code Geass Evangelion and Gundam did
before it's likely the genre will fade
more and more into obscurity if that
does happen though if after all this it
remains a shadow of its former self it's
a legacy that will never be forgotten
it's influenced not only the culture of
anime but the culture of the entire
nation of Japan and considering its
instrumentality in the evolution of the
medium of animes concerns it is one of
the most important John Rizzo anime has
ever had a look into the history of
mecha is a look into the history of
anime itself and whether you're aware of
it or not whether you consider yourself
a mecha fan or flat-out can't stand the
idea it's very likely that some of your
favorite shows wouldn't exist without it
because the same can be said for me I
never really saw the big appeal to them
sure there were shows I liked but
nothing pushed me over the edge to fully
dive into the subculture it created look
I like technology as much as the next
guy but calm down lads it's just an
oversized tow truck with legs that was
until I found myself standing in front
of one in my latest trip to Japan here
stood a full-sized rx0 unicorn Gundam 65
foot of pure
awesome watching these things on TV is
hard to get a perspective of just how
big they are but actually standing at
the base looking up at this metallic
Goliath towering above you walking
around imagining the gravity a force
that would be exerted if this 49 time
beast could take a step marveling at the
thought of a literal [ __ ] building
running at you it dawned on me why these
things have been such a big part of
anime history why they've been there
from the very beginning and why they've
become so symbolic for the medium we all
love giant robots are [ __ ] awesome
[Music]
hey guys hope you enjoyed the video I'm
just gonna do my patreon shoutouts ID
today because [ __ ] it thank you very
much this month to Lee Watts matey
malabon and big black hawk sixty sisters
one zero zero eight six Elliott for a
boat on Borg and everyone else a patron
helped me to support me for this month
and making this video possible this
video took a monumental amount of work
so any help on patreon will be greatly
appreciated because I'd love to do more
big Jonah breakdowns in the future but I
don't even know if this is gonna do as
well as my normal videos anyway that's
it from me I've been Giga can I will see
you all next time